[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
posté devant la fenêtre je guette
désormais seul et à fabien tout boosté
devant la fenêtre je regrette denis
avançons j'ai maintenant que tu as
[Musique]
à la faveur de l'automne
bien 7 pouces mais
audi 1 2 3 qui tint comme mont sutton
tel iai a réellement dit vivait toujours
le téléphone de temps que tu daignes
m'appelait coup tu te décides enfants
[Musique]
toi tu es à lyon deux garçons qu'ils en
donnent la monotonie d'amis
ed
mais
[Musique]
et
à la faveur de l'automne
viens 7 pouces mais
encore 10 1 2
trois quêtes impôts quand on fredonne de
vieillesse
à la donne
ancolie seco
2 super scoop it abarth
[Musique]
oh
à la faveur de l'automne
[Musique]
oh
bord
homo comment ai-je pu seulement être
aussi bête trop m'avait prévenu voici la
berri craie
l amo manquerait plus que le mauvais
temps si m hugo d'appui
j'aurais pu
tout perdre
[Musique]
pendant tout l'automne revient 7 pouces
humer
ancolie ardue
trois quêtes encore mon scooter de
vieillards mélodies par la fra vendu le
temps tu redonnes hammam et
ancolie ses cours
le scoop it
alpha border
auteur
oh
nord
[Musique]
comme au bon moment
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]